housing our mouths my name is P welcome
to my game yes the best goodbye legend
of the brofist this game is my favorite
game I may be a little biased but hey in
the last episode we beat the first
levels Oh actually we got a lot of
Brooklands let's unlock some new things
oh that pageant ever had that that looks
beautiful
ah okay sorry attacks stay focused we
need Edgar's parts they're super
powerful I'll show them how they're
works
Maia right is super awesome to each
character of the game has like a their
individual special attack but it's very
expensive do we have everything we need
you know what let's unlock some hearts
for prototype
I need that love and maybe okay we're
good to can move on to the next level
we're gonna play this one on hard this
level is so hard it's gorgeous
I love this style of it so where we left
off markiplier saved us in his jet we're
like straight-up murdering all these
barrels now Mike please
that's it back a plane
triple dot triple dash
[Music]
but it's the backup plane come on come
on mark
you have got to be kidding me god damn
and make you pick a lot of other pugs
get their own little plane I'm so happy
we could do that
there we go baby barrels kill the BA
kill them ah okay this is so much easier
on I'm playing a piece he kisses e for
easier for me to record it that way but
man it's so much easier to play as well
yes maybe the game will come out on PC
in the future who knows oh god if you
notice like if you look closely on the
explosions oh got a killer unicorns get
a lot of Brooklands from jewnicorns more
unicorn keep killing hey [ __ ] you
[ __ ] if you look closely at the
explosions oh god there's so much going
on I can't game out there actually
brofist you see it it's pretty cool nice
details a lot of nice touches like that
in the game gotta keep collecting bro
points yes kill all those [ __ ]
ducklings okay we're not doing too well
that was so [ __ ] close Jesus Christ
Oh got your fudge kill them as well they
are a lot of Brooklands yes I got killer
what oh god that was so close no a god
oh well we got a lot of Brooklyn I'm a
horrible person
Oh God give me a [ __ ] break
literally this plane doesn't have a
break okay this is so hard when you get
hit oh there we go
full life okay goddamn ducks I'm
sweating
sorry ducks sorry alright so sorry okay
we're back in action baby watch Center
battle how it's the up in disguise oh my
god this bus is so hard
come on I hope I can do it you're mighty
flying tank dude
oops I click that sorry okay still got
it baby
okkkk oh god no I'm so bad at these ah
oh god yes okay we got one of them come
on come on come on you just got to be
careful yes we got two of them Wow come
on kill all the barrels there's way too
many barrels in this left get all the
Brooklands
whoo okay where's the next one oh yeah
it's the tank oh god those stars you got
to keep moving at this part I forgot no
I got hit goddamn it just so much damage
[Music]
yes we got it we got it
awesome two more two more steps if you
beat this one on the first try man
you're a boss okay what's your next one
these
come on I hate that mess house come on
I'm trying so hard this is my own game I
got to look good
okay last part yeah bit in the game on
high better have a got better I got my
on my side babe come on
yes oh god you can't get into him people
die if they get killed no one my head
one more head come on
no yes Oh me and my damn power I'm so
happy
whoa
oh and I love this game your brother in
the North Pole
that's a good question better pet why
where's Edgar alright we beat another
level we get a [ __ ] ton of broke hoi's
cousin beatin heart that kind of looks
like a but I like that jet fighter
completed can you beat my score 117 how
about ten hundred seventy I don't think
so I'm gonna get out of this awesome
plane
stupid video game rules goddamn video
games rule I love this game
that's a reference for Donkey Kong
Country it's one of my favorite games so
glad we got a little little homage up to
that alright we're back at that the menu
we can unlock markiplier you have to
interact with their characters to unlock
them cannon gets unlocked here in the
ice poles shack somewhere here and then
I want you to file anything as stupid as
you can see when you beat a level on
hard you get a barrel instead of a duck
and you can check your progress here how
many hard to collected I'm gonna
characters you unlock on all of the
patches so we got a 10 percent
completion so far total broke owns all
that kind of stuff
let's see if we can unlock energy shield
that's really good let's sound like that
and let's make sure that we unlock
marquee move BAM
what does it say a dynamic of generous
internet personality with pink facial
peel off city is the baddest video game
commentator as well as a very good
sidekick you can't hit it
I agree okay well let's just jump into
the next level alright actually you know
what I want to play as myself again I'll
place mark next one cuz we'll have Edgar
fart and they're really useful in this
level all right we're in the sky now we
got a message
[Music]
I love my sis I log it's so good I just
like I'm trying to save the world it
might say sis like give me phone okay
here we go more barrels not a problem
get out of here all murder baby barrels
everyday son there we go so underneath
you can find something maybe a patch
nope sometimes it's just hearts I'm
running a full of hard to get more Brook
lines so it's really good to keep like I
never get hit never mind then [ __ ]
hell [ __ ] Oh God
meteors and your Forge activate
bartender get barred good job again and
your smarts
can stop meteors don't question it ah
[ __ ] I guess they go out fast
literally Edgar farts are deadly like I
have experienced them it's not funny
Oh God [ __ ] hell when is it end
I can't I hate the metal barrels [ __ ]
you metal barrel there we go
this level is so beautiful there's a
reference going on in the amount of
reference but it a little do you see the
Illuminati confirmed oh god it's a
fangirl the cow is a fangirl the god
that was close now damn it
I don't need hearts or dubrow coins okay
here we go
no [ __ ] oh [ __ ] almost died Jesus Christ
can I do this oh I'll go G [ __ ] alright
let's just go this way alright
close enough well isn't it so then they
refill after a little while can i
activate their crap
yes I need some hearts thanks doc thanks
dr. crab I think you can upgrade dr.
crab as well for oh [ __ ] what am i doing
oh my god I can't [ __ ] up now ah No
my y'all paying for this it's okay I
still have a card so I still have Edgar
farts hello Would Edgar stand still he's
just like like way to hyperactive just
like just let go to let go
I'm sorry baby barrel Oh goddamn I could
have unlock more oh well
bro flag we get all the hearts doing
really well oh [ __ ] activate Edgar farts
fart Edgar yes [ __ ] you meteors and
Ducks you ain't got [ __ ] on me ow God
Oh God oh [ __ ] the meteors are killing
the Ducks I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna go [ __ ] this life is too short
oh god sanic marrows aah aah aah
yes how did I get hit there what the
[ __ ] it's okay okay we got all the bro
codes dammit
keep getting a hit activate dr. crab
again so it's really useful to have all
the abilities in the game I think
there's a glitch no never mind is just a
feature that makes dr. Pam take a little
longer to activate goddamnit I need more
patches okay here we go let's keep going
sorry if you can see my mouse I forgot
to hide it okay
brap boom [ __ ] get out the way
yes how do I get hit there what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you barrels I told you if you
donate barrels before you show us how
well after this game
oh god it's another fan girl Lisa please
I don't know god damn it Lisa oh god
don't breathe in the barrel smoke they
save it down here then edgar farts just
kidding there's nothing no see no gas
more deadly than edgar farts
there you go barrel [ __ ] no ducks how
am I gonna [ __ ] how am I gonna do that
maybe if I jump with a duck there we go
yes yes botch yes ah come on I need to
activate dr. crab again as soon as the
coast is clear oh god what is happening
oh [ __ ] chase s Christ there's blood
everywhere
this gameis is ridiculous I love it okay
there we go dr. crab again dr. crab is
my boo there we go we're all this by the
end I love if you get killed by that
killer whale it's insta death it's kind
of mean but leads to the North Pole
I have no other choice let's go baby
whoo all right two levels and hard get
good urge I am put a pang
okay is that only fifty I only got 50
points
does that make sense I don't think that
makes sense
295 let's go with that did it it did it
who do do do all right so now let's use
the America player Nick the bad luck any
patches man I'm gonna miss the patch
they're damaged uh what do we got
whatever guy would have a guy what have
we got marks ability needs a thousand
points but it's beautiful as mustache
just flows out in the wind actually
Mark's character isn't that great on
this level either I will play I say my
promise but not in the bro level this
level is terrifying
there's no one ever gets this on the
first try at the beginning is really
funny to watch like people try this
level out for the first time all right
another message that theme by the way
with the ringtone is by Rumi do you
remember do you YouTube gamer all the
suckers number Russia won he did an
amazing job
okay here we go
why is there t-rex in the subway
I don't know see you got to run forward
everyone just backs off and they inside
i all right here we go is there a secret
yes
emo Kibo of course oh god I hate those
these you gotta get rid of these
you got a dodge and then get them that's
how you kill them that really [ __ ]
tricky though oh so in the subway a lot
of scared oh god the rats [ __ ] the rats
a lot of scary stuff happening in subway
so you got to keep moving okay I'm just
gonna go ahead and activate at your
farts here those Slenderman things I
hate them come on I need it I need this
I need this yes another pad the rat T&T
let's activate dr. crab you'd really
have to be really tactics in this game
if you're gonna be in an unlike harder
difficulties cuz it gets like legit
really [ __ ] hard barrel was here how
did it how would it barrel spray
graffiti I don't even know let's do a
cool shot damn ago
damnit I suck now oh god they're
everywhere you have to stay in the
center here it's really [ __ ] creepy I
hate it
your insta die if you if you don't do it
oh god the rats just come here then go
away I think there's a lot of hard
summer here no nevermind [ __ ] that
oh my god okay I really want to do this
okay so I have to survive and chip off
ah ah that was so close I have to
survival until the subway comes come on
jumped over me
I think you're first get the t-rex get
it yes hahaha and Gaspard can kill
t-rex's oh this always here where's the
entrance first entrance there let's go
yeah turn and our fall bar back oh
there's lovely so intense I can't even I
literally cannot what do we got hundred
and party [ __ ] yeah
okay doing great that was another three
levels should we do one more
should we do one more let's do let's
play with mark you know what let's play
with mark and do what Marcus I said I
was gonna do mark he doesn't we don't
have a powerup yet this is the 360
no-scope ability we're still doing it on
hard this is so hard
having a general barrel my brother I
won't let you get away with this
I've contained your French now Shannon
oh it's on baby
sir markiplier has his little character
tiny bucks Tim these seals man I hate
them just kill them fast I'm sorry I
know they're cute I know they're suck
yet but [ __ ] em oh god oh god
rampage god damnit what yeah this level
is really hard cuz you actually saw God
Lee said now you got a dodge here up
snow snow snow in this ah Sam still
markiplier yeah bet there we go in the
snow we got a Marcia patch awesome okay
kill them kill this kill the little
[ __ ] kill them all [ __ ] there we
go Oh activate activate shield oh [ __ ]
that was in the last second wasn't it
huh
there we go there we go you got to be
fast here oh god I think we're running
out of time
no those [ __ ] ah guys give me a break
here I think I could actually [ __ ] up
here I'm not even kidding come on damn
it okay
full health well hell it's so cute every
character has like their little little
guy or little guys protecting you
it's this adorable damnit I got a
[ __ ] shape up because I need a man
who can make me satisfied okay here we
go
don't slide out this time
damnit I wanted a patch okay here we go
Bam Bam oh god Lisa I think there's a
patch here bully patch okay there we go
BAM [ __ ] okay I'm so focused oh this is
so tricky go go go go go Lisa
ow slide no no no tiny box damn I'm so
oh god it looks so sad
it looks so sad try me buck damn I'm
sorry we did it Oh
oh that was that was close I was really
[ __ ] close
alright so tweet me hashtag beat the bro
if you beat the level with a better
score than I did that was glaciers so
much going to play this game
I love playing this game for you bros
I'm gonna take a break here because
Scott dam and I've been talking to logic
but thank you so much for watching thank
you so much for checking out the game
download it in the description
Amazon android/ios you got it baby and
I'll see you bros in the next one
stay awesome bros